Ваша мотивація очолити"Укроборонпром"?
Мені подобається братися за доволі брудні, складні і нереформовані справи. І цей мій найбільший драйв.
Чи реально добудувати крейсер "Україна"?
Ми будемо розглядати можливість продажу цього крейсера.
Чи є в "Укроборонпрому "міжнародні замовлення?
Повідомлення з Перу, де ми нещодавно продали один літак.
Якщо Вам будуть заважати,які ваші дії?
Так мені вже заважають, але це не має бути перепоною.
Погрози були?
Поки лише психологічний тиск.
Застарілий концерн "Укроборонпром" має перетворитися на успішне підприємство.
Як це завдання президента Зеленського виконуватимуть в державному концерні?
І який зиск від цього матимуть ЗСУ?
Про це будемо говоритиз новим головою "Укроборонпрому" Айварасом Абромавичусом.
Доброго дня!
Корупція й "Укроборонпром" за останні кілька років - майже синоніми.
Ви не боїтеся нових корупційних скандалів?
Ризики мені відомі.
Я думаю, що структура повністю не підлягала реформуванню
не те, що останні кілька років, а останні усі 30 років.
І за останні три місяці я об’їздив кілька десятків заводів. Проблематика мені відома.
Великі борги з заробітної плати, обладнання, яке підлягає терміновій модернізації,
проблеми з поставками на фронт.
Будемо працювати над покращенням співпраці з правоохоронними органами.
Як Ви збираєтесь протистояти цій фактично системній та глибиннійкорупції?
Будемо заводити людей на реформу закупівель, тих, які стояли біля витоків системи Prozorro.
"Укроборонпром" буде змінюватися тільки тоді,
коли велика кількість людей, які не мають нічого спільного з минулим "Укроборонпрому",
нічого спільного з Міноборони в минулому, з іншими інституціями, яких поглинула корупція.
Вони прийдуть і почнуть реформувати.
Чи встигли Ви вже зрозуміти обсяг от цих всіх корупційних махінацій,
які відбувалися в "Укроборонпромі"?
Обіг компанії минулого року - це 1,4 млрд гривень.
Тому можна лише гадати, скажімо, про неефективність,
корупцію, які досягали там 10 або більше відсотків.
Але те, що гроші проходили повз держбюджет, повз концерн -
так, скоріше за все, так було.
Також в "Укроборонпромі" всередині тільки в Києві є 27 компаній з величезною кількістю
різного роду нерухомості - це десятки тисяч різних споруд та будівель.
Вони роками, звичайно, розграбовувалися.
На жаль, в нас є велика заборгованість з зарплати - 1,1 млрд гривень на 40 підприємствах.
Одна з моїх цілей - до кінця року серйозно почати зменшувати заборгованість заробітної зарплати.
Там будуть нові керівники? Бо на цих підприємствах вкрай важка ситуація.
Звичайно, змінимо.
Вважаю, що треба ухвалити окремий закон про оздоровлення ОПК,
в тому числі шляхом списання великої заборгованості,
тому що деякі підприємства історично, з різних причин потрапили в процедуру банкрутства.
Легендарне підприємство завод імені Малишева, Харківський авіаційний завод,
Миколаївський суднобудівний та багато інших.
Ми мусимо відновити авіабудівництво, інші напрямки.
В тому числі шляхом створення спільного виробництва з всесвітніми гігантами.
Україна хоче створити "москітний" флот. Чи реально це зробити на вітчизняних ресурсах?
Треба сісти та чітко порахувати.
Військові, виходячи зі свого бюджету, з потреб держави,
мають вирішити, яка ППО, який флот нам потрібен.
Це абсолютно стратегічні питання, які мають відношення до доктрини оборони країни.
Чи реально добудувати крейсер "Україна", який стоїть вже кілька років у Миколаєві?
В України немає потреби в крейсері такого масштабу,
тому ми будемо розглядати можливість продажу цього крейсера.
Ми будемо будувати інші кораблі - меншого масштабу в більшій кількості,
знову таки, виходячи з потреб наших Збройних сил.
Україна дедалі більше зосереджується на ремонті старих літаків та вертольотів.
А як же новаaвiатехніка?Чи є в планах закупівля нових літаків?
Ще передчасно це озвучувати, в тому числі через те, щоб наші плани не стали відомі нашим ворогам.
Але термін експлуатації наших літаків спливає з кожним роком,
і вирішення питання про оновлення нашого авіафлоту наближається.
В "Укроборонпромі" приблизно 100 підприємств. Чи буде частина з нихліквідована?
Вже кілька десятків підприємств знаходяться в стадії ліквідації.
Ядро концерну - це не більше20-25 підприємств. Треба усі сили кинути на найкращі підприємства.
Решту - віддати в приватну ініціативу після того, як ми в підсумку проведемо інвентаризацію.
Дещо закрити, а основну масу об’єднати в більш велике підприємство.
Ви знаєте, чому на полігонах останні кілька років постійно вибухають боєприпаси?
Я можу собі уявити причини, тому що на більшості підприємств "Укроборонпрому"
на великих територіях просто неба лежить велика кількість різного виду техніки.
Тому я можу припустити, що в нас зі зберіганням боєприпасів є проблеми.
Але це проблема ані минулого року, ані позаминулого року.
Це системна проблема, яку треба вирішувати.
І це не прерогатива "Укроборонпрому", цим займаються військові.
Я їм не радник, але вважаю, що треба закуповувати нове, а старе утилізувати.
І прикро для іміджу крани, армії, що є ці вибухи.
Тому що ми добре розуміємо, в яких великих сумах обчислюються втрати.
Чому Ви не хочете, щоб акціонером "Укроборонпрому" було Міноборони?
У Міноборони є свої підприємства ремонтні, і вони в дуже поганому стані.
Історично вони довели, що їм складно керувати держпідприємствами.
Адже вони військові люди.
Також виникне конфлікт інтересів, якщо вони будуть акціонерами "Укроборонпрому".
Тому я вважаю, що ось це рішення, де Мінекономіки практично очолює "Укроборонпром" -
це правильне рішення.
Чи є в "Укроборонрому" міжнародні замовлення, які треба виконати? Іякі, приміром, невиконані?
Це називаєтьсяBusiness as usual.
Такі ситуації в нас виникають постійно.
Але ми продовжуємо продавати озброєння по всіх куточках світу.
Мої колеги пишуть мені повідомлення з Перу, де ми нещодавно продали один літак.
Мої колеги наразі знаходяться в Катарі, Афганістані, інших країнах.
Тому робота кипить. В нас є висококласні експортери.
Чи буде вся ця інформація про контракти, як і раніше, закритою?
Деякі контракти, розміри, скажімо, вартість, країни постачання - вони будуть оприлюднюватися.
Єдине, що ми не будемо розкривати, так це конкретні технічні параметри певних озброєнь.
Ваше призначення відбулося без конкурсу.
Але тоді, влітку, Ви пояснили це тим, що треба було терміново брати ситуацію під контроль,
бо почали надходити негативні сигнали від контрагентів та міжнародних партнерів України.
Чи дійсно йшлося про якісь репутаційні втрати?
"Укроборонпром" має репутаційні втрати щодня.
На міжнародних ринках ми втрачаємо імідж,
в нас в країні лише за липень відбулося 26 обшуків у різних компаніях концерну.
І вже минулий менеджмент відчув, що зміни керівників невідворотні
і почали діяти, скажімо так, не дуже добре.
Був змінений статут компанії  "Укрспецекспорт", де грошові потоки найбільші.
Практично "Укрспецекспорт" пішов у вільне плавання від концерну "Укроборонпром".
Почали зливати в медіа доволі секретні матеріали щодо окремих контрактів.
І, звичайно, президент, побачивши це, сказав, що, мовляв, Айварас, в нас немає часу,
ти маєш стати генеральним директором.
До кінця року ми проведемо відкритий конкурс, де, я сподіваюся, оберемо генерального директора,
який буде працювати вже на довгостроковій основі.
Але чи я заходжу в цю компанію надовго як гендиректор,
чи-то голова Наглядової ради, покаже час.
Вас називали претендентом на посаду прем’єра. Ви відмовилися?
Ні, така пропозиція у підсумку мені не надійшла.
В підсумку був обраний прем'єром Олексій Гончарук,
якого я приймав на роботу 4 роки тому в новостворений Офіс ефективного регулювання.
Можете зараз сказати, що саме Вас так обурило у2016-ому році,
коли Ви подали у відставкуз посади міністра економічного розвитку і торгівлі?
Саме в той чася працював з багатьма корупційними схемами.
Великий штраф у вигляді кількох мільярдів доларів на компанію "Укрнафта" Коломойського, інші заходи.
В принципі ми працювали з дуже складними і небезпечними темами,
і от, коли президентська вертикаль вирішує мене якимось чином провчити,
то це, на жаль, не має нічого спільного з реформуванням країни.
У2016році, коли Ви подали у відставку, Ви казали, що не хочете бути "ширмоюдлявідвертої корупції".
Історія може повторитися…
Сподіваюся, що історія не повториться. І кожен буде робити свою справу.
І я особисто вірю в щирі наміри діючого президента.
Якщо Вам будуть заважати,які Ваші дії?
Так мені вже заважають, але це не має бути перепоною.
Дивіться, я незалежна людина фінансово,
незалежний від якихось олігархічних фінансово-промислових груп.
Звичайно, коли будуть якісь серйозні нав’язування кадрів,
які просто будуть дискредитувати реформи, я про це заявлятиму.
Погрози були?
Ні. Фізичної розправи - ні. Поки є лише психологічний тиск.
Він неприємний, дещо повторюється таким же шляхом, як це відбувалося, коли я був міністром.
Нові види сучасної та надсучасної зброї MadeinUkraine.
Наскільки це реалістично, щоб цю продукцію купували інші країни?
Є окремо взяті напрямки,
в тому числі, ракетобудування,
де в нас достатньо регулярно модифікуються
дуже сучасні види озброєння.
Є напрямки, де в нас не вистачає фінансового ресурсу
на перехід на нову модель окремого виду техніки
Тому для того, щоб по всіх напрямках бути мегасучасними,
для цього знадобляться серйозні капітальні вкладення.
Тому потрібне серйозне оздоровлення сектору,
весь комплекс заходів, з якими це все можливо.
Розробка нової техніки. Чи є молоді талановиті інженери, вчені?
В цілому "Укроборонпром" не є поки що
привабливим роботодавцем, як би це не було сумно.
Але так не має бути. Ми мусимо зробити ребрендинг компанії,
відродити такі компанії як "Антонов",
"Зоря"-"Машпроект", аби молодь пішла туди працювати.
Ваша мотивація очолити"Укроборонпром"?
Я вважаю, що "Укроборонпром" є одним з найбільш не реформованих підприємств в нашій країні.
Мені подобається братися за доволі брудні, складні і не реформовані справи.
І цей мій найбільший драйв.
Як Ви можете підтвердити, що віднині "Укроборонпром" буде більше робити задля ЗСУ?
Я можу це лише пообіцяти від щирого серця.
Я, коли заходив зі своєю командою, ми сказали, що під час каденції президента - за 5 років,
"Укроборонпром" стане геть іншою компанією.
Дуже дякую!
Дякую!